et vous savez quoi aujourd'hui vous
explique comment mettre un petit peu de
magie dans vos vidéos vous explique tout
ça après l'intro
et salut à tous mes amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mais encore et
aujourd'hui on va avoir une petite
astuce super simple pour rendre vos
vidéos un petit peu plus magique
alors comme vous avez pu le voir au
début de cette vidéo l'idée c'est de
faire apparaître des titres des images
des objets dans vos vidéos et
franchement c'est super simple et en
plus ça donne un effet vraiment whaou à
vos vidéos
alors j'entends déjà ce qu'ils vont dire
oui mais toi tu fais sur fine gueule que
tu es tout moi j'ai première ça marche
exactement de la même manière sur
première sur mac ou sur pc - voilà ça
c'est dit allez on y va c'est parti on
ouvre l'ordi alors l'idée pour faire
apparaître un titre une image un objet
ça va être utilisé un masque et de
révéler un petit à petit l'objet qu'on
veut faire apparaître ici nous on va
s'occuper d'un titre alors première
chose j'ai importé mont roches
je vais aller tout simplement ajouter un
titre donc je vais aller ici rechercher
le titre personnalisé et je le fais
glisser ici alors je vais déjà le
renommé ici je vais l'appeler magie
puisque c'est le texte que je veux
qu'ils apparaissent
moi je vais choisir la police ici qui me
plaît bien qui est celle ci ce ne valait
et je vais l'agrandir un petit peu parce
que là c'est trop petit on y voit pas
attention à ne pas agrandir trop parce
que sinon il y aura des morceaux du
titre qui vendent des passes et de mal
donc il faut pas que ce soit plus grand
que ma main maintenant je vais me caler
voilà ici ça démarre à peu près là donc
je vais mettre mon titre ici et bien
vérifier qu'ils ne dépassent pas de ma
main dans haut en bas et quand je vais
me déplacer alors l'attention c'est un
petit peu trop bas puisque j'ai monté ma
main dans le mouvement donc je vais
remonter un petit peu le titre est
vérifié que sur la fin du mouvement
je masque bientôt ok super car
maintenant on va aller chercher les
faits masque de tracé qui va nous
permettre de dessiner un masque
exactement sur la forme qu'on veut alors
vous en mettez pas à aller chercher dans
tous les effets vous tapez ici dans la
barre de recherche masque on l'a même
pas de traces et j'ai tout ici
il est ici je vais aller l'appliquer à
mon titre maintenant je vais ajouter les
points de contrôle pour définir la forme
de monde parce que tout simplement up
hop hop hop on va en mettre un cinquième
au cas où il ait besoin de faire des
ajustements
alors ici vous voyez que mon titre
apparaît moi ce que je veux c'est le
masque et et le révéler au fur et à
mesure alors je vais tout simplement ici
dans les paramètres de ce titre
ici vous voyez j'ai masque de tracé on
va cliquer sur inverser le masque donc
le masque au lieu de cacher l'extérieur
de la zone va cacher l'intérieur ensuite
ce masque on veut qu'il évolue au fil
des mouvements donc on va aller cliquez
ici sur points de contrôle et a ajouté
des qui friment c'est à dire que pour
chaque image on pourra déplacer le
masque et il a évolué à chaque image
maintenant je me plaçais au début de mon
animation et image par image je vais
modifier ce masque donc pour déplacer
image par image on va tout simplement
utiliser les flèches gauche et droite du
clavier
allez c'est parti j'avance ici vous
voyez n'y a pas des masses de mouvement
la maman ici et je vais venir couler le
masque a maintenant up week ici il faut
pas non plus trop dépasser up et
j'avance d'une autre image là on va
faire la seconde up alors le mouvement
est assez rapides donc du coup il pas
beaucoup de qui ferait mal à ajuster
mais si le mouvement est plus lent ça
prendra forcément plus de temps et il y
aura plus de qui freine forcément plus
de d'animation affaires up et voilà une
troisième et s'est terminé mon magie est
apparu voyons ce que ça donne
et voilà le mot magie est apparue par
magie pour peaufiner un petit peu le
tout vous avez vu il ya du fou à cause
du mouvement donc ça c'est complètement
normal
du coup pour rendre l'apparition du
texte un petit peu plus naturelle on va
aller ici d'un adoucissement et on va le
mettre à bloc un allons-y est ce qui va
me permettre d'avoir ici si on regarde
image par image
un espèce de petit fondue qui va rendre
le mouvement un petit peu plus naturel
voyant ce que ça donne ici
et voilà c'est parfait et voilà les amis
s'étaient pas plus compliqué que ça
franchement c'est une astuce qui est
super simple et qui donne un petit côté
whaou avant vidéo un petit côté magic
man que j'aime beaucoup
alors ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que
c'est pas forcément limité à des titres
ça peut être donc des objets ça peut
être des images que vous allez inséré
comme j'ai fait moi dans l'introduction
mais ça peut aussi être des transitions
c'est-à-dire pour passer d'un plan à un
autre on peut utiliser un masque et ça
donnera un effet vraiment sympa aussi
donc encore une fois la seule limite
c'est votre créativité donc il ya tout
un tas de possibilités offertes grâce à
cette astuce donc je vous laisse là
essayer et me dire dans les commentaires
un petit peu ce que vous en aurez pensé
et bien entendu si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit
pouce bleus bien entendu ça fait
toujours plaisir vous pouvez également
vous abonner pour ne rien rater de ce
qui se passera par la suite sur la
chaîne et croyez moi ça va être sympa
cette année 2018 elle s'annonce super
bien et en attendant moi je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
à